Oh which drama is like no other drama
because people curse each other when
there's witch drama hello my name is
Sarah Lyons I'm a witch as you can tell
and I'm a tarot card reader
I've been practicing witchcraft for
about 10 years now and I normally don't
wear hats like this today I'm going to
be watching clips from several movies
and TV show that feature witches and
setting the record straight on just how
accurate some of those depictions are
[Applause]
this movie freaks me out so much when I
was a kid I mean that is how I melt in
the summer when I'm wearing all black
obviously this is a little bit done up
for Hollywood it was one of the first
colorized movies that people got to see
on the big screen
so one of the things that they did to
kind of make oz so much more beautiful
odd and surreal is make the witch green
in it every time you see a green witch
in a Halloween store or you see people
dressing up in costumes of which is
wearing green paint on their face it all
goes back to the Wizard of Oz there's no
previous lore about that I'm doing that
right now
I'm which ID powers I can make these
kind of things happen sorry I can't with
the sparkles I've never made sparkles
appear in the air I don't know what the
point of that is just to walk in and
have like glitter everywhere it is a
little accurate that when you're on a
date with someone whenever the
witchcraft thing comes up the date
either gets a lot more fun or just kind
of dies right there well what do you do
and I read tarot cards and do witchcraft
what do you do you know
not [ __ ] big steel I still alive and
waiting for you
thou hast waited in vain and I will fail
to save I friends justice our failed to
save ice this is one of my favorite
movies I watch it every October and one
of the main tropes throughout
hocus-pocus is Winifred spell book and
how she needs that spell books he could
make them young and beautiful again
which is having spell books that's a
pretty accurate idea of nowadays witches
might call the place where they keep
their spells a book of shadows flying on
broomsticks is a really common trope in
a lot of old witch lore a lot of what
people associate with witches comes from
the old wood cuts that we would see in
Europe of women flying with other
witches on a broomstick to the seventh
the Sabbath is the gathering place of
witches no I don't literally ride a
broomstick
but the Sabbath isn't really a physical
place the way that a lot of witches were
said to fly to the Sabbath was by
rubbing a flying ointment on themselves
and this flying ointment contained herbs
that we now know to be hallucinogenic in
nature so things like belladonna mugwort
flying on a broomstick is the early
modern equivalent of just tripping out
regular skin is fine but you shouldn't
ingest it or put it on your naughty bits
little safety advice for all those
little witches out there watching this
yes I love this movie the ritual that
they do at the beach is actually of a
very common ritual that you do in
witchcraft called calling the corners or
drawing a circle so in a lot of
witchcraft sort of create a circle of
protection around yourself before you
engage in magic and to sort of create
what's called a cone of power wearing
your magic becomes stronger especially
if you're doing it with a group of
people which they were doing we have to
first call the four corners of the
cardinal direction so north south east
and west every witch practices their
craft a little bit differently no two
witches are going to have the same way
that they practice their craft you could
use that as a
a template for a ritual what are you
cooking something smells handsome Serena
you're gonna love it we're making you a
dream date you know it's not an uncommon
thing for which is to cook up a date for
someone to use magic as a form of
attraction inevitably when you tell
someone that you're a witch the first
thing that somebody asks you is if you
can do a love spell for them there's
some controversy actually in the
witchcraft community over love spells
and over the ethics of love spells some
people think that they are coercive and
then therefore shouldn't be used but
some people also think that it's just
the equivalent of maybe putting on a
little bit of makeup and wearing some
nice perfume but it's not so much about
making someone fall in love with you
it's more just about you know opening up
the doors and allowing something like
that to come into your life perhaps I
have done a love spell yeah I've done
kind of attraction spells for myself I'm
going out on a date and I really wanted
to go well I might light a candle I
might say a spell I might do something
of that sort personally if I want
someone to fall in love with me I want
it to be because of me and not be
necessarily wondering if it's because of
a spell
soundtrack for this show is so good my
god I want all their outfits
this is just a boat photoshoot Oh
[Music]
Jessica Lange I mean is there anyone
cooler the idea that modern witches
would burn one another alive if one
transgressed sort of the rules of a
community or coming is it accurate
that's murder and I don't know anybody
who's really down for that having a
ritual sacrifice of someone isn't
something that I know about anybody
doing but MIT hey maybe I'm getting
invited to the wrong parties right I
have cursed people it is not something I
do often because the couple of times
I've done it I've really up some lives
there's a lot of ways to go about laying
a curse on someone or laying a hex on
someone what a binding spell is is kind
of just keeping someone exactly where
they are stopping someone in their
tracks so that they can't bring harm to
you anymore a really common way to do
this is to take a photo of someone and
wrap them up in like black tape and then
put them in the back of your freezer cuz
you're freezing them right where they
stand well I'm so excited for this show
I love the comments
[Music]
our unity
oh I'm so excited oh that's like
everything I want in a TV show I read
the comics so I know a little bit of
what nefarious things that she gets up
to or a girl and this one Sabrina's
having her friggin birthday with the
devil you know he's invited to the party
right in Wicca which is a religion that
uses witchcraft as a part of it there
really isn't a figure called a devil
most weekends don't believe in the devil
they worship a god and a goddess and
often the goddess picked it as sort of a
Horned God
so maybe looking kind of devilish but a
lot of witches do worship the devil or
do use the devil in their craft when
they're talking about the devil sort of
the figure at the crossroads who's an
initiatory figure into the world of
witchcraft if they decide to pull on any
real dark lore whose pleasure which it
kind of seems like they're doing here if
we can really do things with our minds
that's scary so I like now the
depictions of witchcraft are actually
embracing more of the kind of darkness
that was associated with witchcraft for
a long time the witch is an archetype
and a symbol that's been with us for
millennia but maybe don't believe
everything you see in the movies when it
comes to magic and especially witchcraft
truth truly is stranger than fiction
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]